science certainly affects everything we
do but it's also true that we affect the
scientific process
imagine that science and society
communicate through a game of telephone
information is passed from hand to hand
or institution to institution
you see scientists publish research
papers which eventually reach
policymakers who then apply the
knowledge in ways that benefit the world
right
well sort of this picture gets
complicated once you realize that
society creates a climate of social
economic and political factors that
influence scientists and policymakers
the linear game of telephone becomes a
loop and the scientific message is more
likely to become distorted here we can
show you how this loop is formed by
telling the story of asbestos mining in
South Africa
wait wait wait you've probably heard of
asbestos but do you really know what it
is asbestos is a mineral that's stronger
than steel inflammable sound absorbent
and flexible which makes it an
economically important resource between
1910 and 2002 South Africa was the
world's third largest exporter of
asbestos during that time South Africa
turned a huge profit mining more than 10
million tons of it that's equivalent to
almost 28 Empire State buildings but
let's take a closer look at the social
context in 20th century South Africa
life was divided along racial lines of
apartheid the government enforced
segregation of public spaces medical
care even citizenship with limited
employment opportunities many black
South Africans turned to manual work
like asbestos mining entire families
would work together to drill collect and
separate asbestos from the earth but
asbestos as it turns out is particularly
dangerous to mine although asbestos may
look like solid rock when it's drilled
and blasted by miners it can unravel
into millions of small fibers which
people can breathe in normally when a
foreign substance enters the lungs it
gets digested into mucus and coughed up
but asbestos dust builds up over time
eventually causing inflammation and the
four
Meishan of scar tissue daily exposure to
asbestos may cause serious respiratory
problems that appear later in life
illnesses can lay dormant for decades
within the body such as mesothelioma
which are cancerous tumors that form in
vital organs families of mine workers
knew they were getting sick from
asbestos exposure but the industry
ignored their protests as more people
found out about the dangers of asbestos
how long do you think it took for mines
to start implementing workplace safety
regulations in 1959 scientists presented
extensive research demonstrating that
mesothelioma was unusually common in
South African miners and that even brief
exposure to asbestos could cause
symptoms to appear
it wasn't until 1986 that mining
companies started negotiating with
miners to improve workplace safety it
took over a quarter of a century for
this science to be implemented into
policy what happened here to caused such
a delay between science and action well
remember how society shapes the game of
telephone into a loop between 1959 and
1986 South Africa's economic interests
favoured asbestos mining further
distorting the scientific message
the 1959 publication prompted the mining
industry to fund research on the health
effects of asbestos but this research
wasn't at all designed to examine the
link between workplace conditions and
lung disease for example one study even
attempted to link mesothelioma to a
polio vaccine that most South Africans
hadn't even received meanwhile the mines
continued business as usual while black
laborers protested their unsafe working
conditions in the mid 70s and early 80s
the asbestos trade slowed as both global
and domestic economic pressure against
apartheid increased in 1986 after a
national anti asbestos campaign and
several more strikes the first health
and safety requirements for the asbestos
mining industry were finally put into
place
in the end it took a perfect storm of
social political and economic factors
for science done in the lab to directly
benefit workers in the mine today
scientific discoveries are made at an
accelerated rate all of the new
information goes through a similar
game of telephone the story of his
bestest mining shows us that while
society depends on informed science
scientists also need reminding of social
contexts a study in 2008 for example
showed that carbon nanotubes have a
fiber shape similar to asbestos when
mice were exposed to these nanotubes
they developed mesothelioma like
symptoms billions of dollars are funding
nanotechnology research and carbon
nanotubes can already be found in a
variety of products from sunscreen to
eyeglasses in short scientists have
introduced a promising material but
ongoing research points to potentially
harmful effects of its use sound
familiar
science is a series of social
interactions and especially when it
comes to health any conflicting messages
in the conversation can have serious
consequences people such as science
writers professors and citizen
scientists work against the likelihood
of these miscommunications moving
forward it is important to shorten the
gap between scientists and the public to
fortify the imperfect loop and keep
scientific messages connected to their
social contexts
you